there is a very prominent liberal
streamer commentator I don't who goes by
the name Destiny I don't know his real
name I I have not really watched much of
his stuff I think I was supposed to
debate him at one point perhaps we'll do
that into the future
uh Destiny from what I gather has been
in an open marriage and has
defended uh his wife he and his wife
sleeping with other people uh our buddy
sovereign over here was on the whatever
podcast and warned him that this would
likely not end well God forbid this
happens will it be fun if this open
relationship ends up causing things to
fall apart down the line if one of you
guys finds yourself in a uh an
entanglement so to speak with with on
with somebody who you might find a
deeper connection with than the other
person like if that causes the
relationship to to fall apart that
probably wouldn't be very fun no it
would be horrible and it would be sad do
you guys have a high degree of
confidence that your marriage will last
for decades I mean I married her without
a prenup so I hope so okay or else this
motherfucker's going to be he married
her without a prenup good on him
actually that's that's great not good on
him to sleep around with other people
and to let his wife sleep around with
other people uh he explains why why he
decided to start doing that on the same
show best sexual partners that I've had
in my life were all the people that I
were in the long-term relationships with
like on a one night stand like it's hard
to know like one I even fun sexually
depending on what you're looking for I
can agree that the longer you're with
somebody the better sex gets so why is
she not enough why is she not enough
it's I mean like it's kind of like
asking it's kind of like if you've got
like a close friend but then you've got
other friends like well why is that one
friend not enough because in life
sometimes variety is fun sometimes I
want to be with a girl that's Hispanic
or Asian sometimes I want to be with
somebody that is something friendship I
didn't say marriage was a friendship but
marriage to me isn't just about my a lot
of aspects to my marriage that I share
with my wife that's really unique to my
wife that I don't share with other
people is just not one of those
things that's not good that's not good
uh anyway you know how the story ends
even if you've never heard of any of
these people uh they're getting divorced
very sad uh not going to make fun of him
a lot of conservatives seem to be making
fun of this guy because his wife is
leaving him I think it's very sad and I
hope they patch it up and just get back
together and stop sleeping with other
people I think hope that's good I'm
entirely opposed to divorce and so it
would be good if they just did that I
don't know the story she left him for
some guy or whatever um the reason I
even mention the
story is is not even really about
marriage or relationships it's just a
broader point about human behavior which
is
that things that have always been
true are very likely still true
today and that seems like a really
simple point but people get confed
confused about it right now go to higher
bond.com if you are single or know
someone who's single you've probably
seen or heard about all the insane
dating apps out there what if I told you
there were a dating app that actually
cares about your morals and biblical
values well now there is with a new
dating app called a higher Bond higher
bond is a new Christian dating app built
to be safer less stressful and more
Christ centered higher bond is
completely different from anything else
out there there's no addictive swiping
the focus is truly on quality over
quantity and it's designed to form
lasting marriages higher bond is a
Christian company that is veteran owned
by a husband and wife looking to change
the way Christian singles meet online
it's no secret that big tech companies
are against other companies like higher
bond in fact big tech companies would
would highlight the word Christian on on
the ad copy for higher Bond they say
yeah this this is violative you can't
include that in your ads our society and
our country need what higher bond is
doing if you're single you need to check
out higher bond.com sign up before
December 31st get three months of higher
Bond premium absolutely free that is
higher bond.com today right now go to
goodranchers.com use code NES what do
green eggs and your Christmas dinner
have in common they both need a ham to
be complete not just any ham but a
spiral cut Heritage pork Masterpiece
from good ranchers that's the kind of
ham that'll steal the show at your
family gathering guess what you get it
for free with any good ranchers
subscription that's a whopping $99 value
that you get for free in your first
order you know what I had last night
Juicy delicious chicken you know where I
get my chicken and my steak and all my
meat basically is from good ranchers and
it is just the best stuff out there the
price is unbelievable you get freebies
like this $99 ham it's just completely
insane simply subscribe to any box you
will get your totally free Christmas ham
included in any order the subscription
is amazing get 25 bucks off every order
a free gift in every third Buck and free
shipping on express delivery the best
part is knowing exactly where your meat
comes from and that is through a local
American Farm here's the Scoop
goodranchers.com subscribe to with code
nolles to claim your free Limited stock
Christmas ham before they sell out act
fast this offer won't last forever order
before December 11th for guaranteed
delivery by Christmas head on over to
goodranchers.com use code noes kwes when
you subscribe to get your free 10 pound
Christmas ham don't settle for the old
holiday Fair elevate your Feast with
good ranchers this year good ranchers
American Meat delivered things that have
always been true for all of human
history
everywhere probably did
just radically change in the last five
or 10 years really like we've pretended
that they've changed in the last five or
10 years but they probably
haven't because they've always been true
everywhere on Earth there might be a
reason
why things have always been a certain
way everywhere
forever and we might not have the
ability through sheer tyranny of will to
just upend or totally reverse them and
invert them
overnight it it has always been the case
that if you and your wife sleep with
other people your marriage is going to
be weaker and you're more likely to get
divorced that was true yesterday it's
true today it's going to be true
tomorrow it has always been the case
that marriage involves sexual difference
we forgot that one isn't that crazy we
just that was true for all of history
and then like 8 years ago we just
totally upended that one and pretended
that it doesn't but obviously it does
and that and you you see so much more
confusion about marriage he says
marriage is kind of like you and your
buddies no it's not it actually isn't
like you and your buddies marriage is
different well you you like having
multiple friends that's true I do like
having multiple friends though having a
really good friend is kind of rare
actually you don't have a hundred really
good friends you have a handful at at
most most people are lucky if they have
one really good
friend but yeah yes you can have
multiple friends friends are different
than
spouses spouses for instance have to be
of the opposite sex you have to
complement one another physically and
probably spiritually and intellectually
too uh it marriage is ordered toward
producing children it's not true of
friendships maybe some friendships but
shouldn't be that's that's that's
something else that would distinguish it
it's uh for forming the basic political
unit of society which is the family is
distinct from other webs and types of
networks just different that's always
been
true it's going to be
true it's going to be true tomorrow so
in the case of this streamer guy I hope
they hope they patch it up but for all
of you take it as a warning the go the
gods of the copy book headings come back
man what a great clip that was now hold
up hold up hey hold up ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael nlls podcast
we'll see you next time